it's time for our scene and unseen
segment we explore the cultural stories
of the day and for that we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo all
right raymond some
female abortion activists have started
what they're calling is a sex strike
movement that is correct they they are
refusing to have sex until abortion
rights are enshrined federally in the
law so we took to the streets to get a
common man's reaction
do you think that's effective at all i i
don't think so because i don't not
enough people are going to do it i don't
think that anybody's going to go on
strike against sex because it feels so
good and it's also a business
everybody's always going to want to have
sex sex strike a sex strike
i guess that's great for women who can
choose not to have sex i'm not sure how
i'm not sure if it's going to change
much what if we use our most powerful
protesting option
and withhold sex from penises
until this is made right i think that's
a horrible idea and that's not an
effective way to
handle abortion at all i don't think
it'd be effective i think it's going to
be more aggressive than
necessary i think it's going to be
a little bit backwards in the sex strike
protest probably won't work
i mean i'd be willing to give it a shot
if it would is that a good or effective
approach
i would say i agree with it
really
now do you agree with me i don't really
understand what a sex strike is to be
honest a sex strike is where the girl
would not have sex with you
oh
um i think it varies person by person
but
yeah that's a tough one
i noticed he got very sober after that
explanation
not surprising women in the world have
conducted sex strikes in history we have
more power than we think we have and
some of it could be right in the bedroom
i think that women have the right to do
with their bodies whatever they
want to do and so i support people in
this movement i think a sex strike is
the way to go to
awaken people's attention i don't really
have a comment on that so you would be
you would be prepared to have your
girlfriend or significant other go on a
strike until abortion is legal national
see i don't got no girlfriend so i can't
really say that but um i mean again if
they want to do that they want to live
their life i love them you know i'm
going to support them like you'd be
willing to embrace celibacy bro like
because i ain't going like
how long cc
i don't know
i don't disagree with the roe v wade
thing you need to make a good decision
on who you're going to have a child with
period like 60 of the who's not our race
are suffering from the abortion we need
to make better decisions our women need
to make better decisions of who our hat
they're having children with your
reaction to the sex strike idea
you think that's effective i think it
can be it's never really i mean like but
at the same time like are women really
gonna do that women been on strike
they've been on strength
most guys are not with anybody so i mean
what's the difference what's that going
to hurt us
laura okay i love him i have to tell you
this was insightful for a couple of
reasons first of all it's a clever
protest because a sex strike removes the
controversy entirely because you don't
need abortions right but it was sad what
that gentleman pointed out the
loneliness the estrangement that this
recreational sex is created for this
generation and the last couple
it's it's sad because without happy and
loving couples you can't have happy and
loving families so that was that guy was
awesome
i said to raymond you got a brain i said
is there any conservative in new york at
all he's like wait that's the end of it
coming up and laura in the heat of this
abortion battle inexplicably
nancy pelosi attended a papal mass at
the vatican today the speaker has been
forbidden from presenting herself to for
communion in her home diocese of san
francisco due to her advocacy for
abortion still there she was today
glad-handing with the pope and taking
communion you know i got to tell you my
phone blew up when people saw this what
we do is as important as what we say and
the pope says the liturgy should be a
source of unity a way to protect our
communion i don't know how this image
does that in fact i think it estranges
people from whatever catholic doctrine
or belief might be um and pelosi was not
the only public figure seeking cover
this week that's right the creator of
one of the most popular tv shows of all
time friends marta kaufman for years
brushed off complaints that the show was
not diverse enough but now she's come to
a new understanding now in an interview
kaufman says
it is her internalized systemic racism
that caused the lack of inclusivity on
the very popular show here she is
discussing the problem
it was to a certain extent a product of
the time period
and of my own ignorance you know there
were black shows there were white shows
there weren't a lot of shows that were
interracial i guess at the time
i was thinking this is what i know
this is what i know
in expiation for insensitivity laura
over the show she created 28 years ago
kaufman is donating four million dollars
to brandeis university to fund a
professorship in african and amer
african-american studies i know this
story has you amped you were a big
friends fan well here's what i don't
like is going back and like you go back
in time and say no this doesn't count
this was bad this
it was a different
it was a different time but she feels
the need to publicly you know
self-flagellate
and how much do you make on friends
hundreds of millions and syndicates i
mean remember remember they got their
last contract all the uh aniston and and
all the millionaire a million for each
episode so if they're really serious
about this you gotta go more than the
four mil that's not enough look she can
spend her money anyway she wants my
question is do you want to help the
black community why are you giving four
million dollars to brandeis right and
help the black community there are tons
of great faith-based demario davis's
program that actually mentor young black
people all right raymond we gotta go
they're yelling at me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else